ما اهميه هذه التاكيدات الرسميه للادعاء
السويدي حول وجود عمل تخريبي استهدف خطوط
انابيب بنور
ستريميه لكشف سر ما حدث بمعنى ان نحن
عندما وقع التفجير والتسرب الغاز في
منطقتين في ااا في بحر البلطيق كما تذكر
المنطقه تابعه للسويد ومنطقه الدنمارك كان
هناك كثير من التحليلات النظريات التكهنات
انه عمل تخريب او حادث او مقصود واتهامات
واتهامات متبادله الان نحن اول امام اول
همم تقرير قرار رسمي يصدر عن مدعن عام
سويدي يقول انه عمل تخريبي الا انها خطوه
اولى منقوصه طالما انها لم تحدد من هي
الجهه الفاعله او
القادره على القيام بهذا العمل التخريب في
الوقت نفسه فاذا يجب اخذ بعين الاعتبار ان
هذا التحقيق ليس همم الوحيد الذي يحقق في
ما جرى في نور ستريم هناك تحقيق الدنماركي
الذي همم
رجح ان يكون هناك همم تفجير وهناك التحقيق
لشركه غاز بروم المشغله المالكه بشكل
اساسي للخطوط التي ارسلت ايضا بواخر وحصلت
على تصاريح بالدخول الى المياه الدنماركيه
وقبل هذه السويد والتي تحقق ايضا في هذا
الامر في وقت ان روسيا وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اتهمت صراحه بريطانيا وسربت ما
قالت انه مكالمه بين وزير رئيسه وزراء
السابقه لتراس والوزير وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي تقول ان الامر قد ايه انتهى قد
قضي في يوم تفجير واتهمت صراحه همم بوسكو
بريطانيا بانها وراء هذا التفجير وانا
المستفيد هو الولايات المتحده وفيما نفذ
بطعه حلب بريطانيا وقالت ان هذا غير صحيح
وان هذا ما حكم مازلنا الى حد كبير يعني
بدانا نخرج صح طيب المربع الاول ان العمل
تخريبي لكن ما نزلنا همم على مقربه جدا
هذا المربع اي لانه لم يحدد الفاعل ولا اي
مصلحه لا يمكن القول بانه خضعنا خطوات
كبيره
يعني هذه التاكيدات هناك الشق المتعلق
بالتحقيق لا شك سيكون هناك الان مزيد من
الضغوط على من المحققين من كل الاتجاهات
للذهاب ابعد وهناك جمله قالها المدعي ان
استمرار هذه التحقيقات قد يسمح لنا بمعرفه
ان كان هناك اطراف يجب ان تحاكم هذا
الجمله فضفاضه الى حد كبير حتى الان
وبالتالي هناك الشق متعلق بالتحقيق
والتحقيقات في الواقع مستمره ومن سيقبل
بالتحقيق ومن همم سيقبله بمعنى اذا اتهمت
روسيا ستقبل بها او اتهمت بها اخرى هل
ستتهم فعلا جهه هذا الشاب همم مهم جدا لان
الان ستدخل مرحله جديده بعد
مساله انه عمل تخريبي هناك شق المتعلق
بامن المنشات والامن بكل بساطه ما تحت
المياه تحت البحار تحت المحيطات طرح هذا
الامر غداه تفجير نوستريم قبل اشهر الدول
الكبرى دائما لديها همم اساليب حمايه وهمم
منشاتها الان هناك مصالح كبرى دخل تحت
المحيطات تتعلق بخطوط الطاقه تتعلق
بالكوابل مثلا الكوابل الاتصالات الى اخره
راينا منذ اليوم الثاني لهذا التفجير
تعزيز لامن المنشات من قبل مثلا دول
مصدر اساسي للغاز الى اوروبا بعد توقف
الغزال الروسي دول اخرى بريطانيا المنشات
هناك سباق ايضا على هذا الامر وعلى الصعيد
التجسس وليس جديده كان حتى يبان الحرب
البارده لكن اليوم ياخذ منحا اخر مع تشابك
المصالح وتعذر المصالح تحت المياه
والمحيطات هذا الحادث او همم
يمكن بعد يفتح الباب على مزيد من السباق
في هذا الشان ايضا